Shure: 不能违法呀你
Shure: You can't break the law.
Katrina: 我唱的是国歌
Katrina: I'm singing the national anthem.
Katrina: 中华人民共和国国歌
Katrina: The national anthem of the People's Republic of China.
Katrina: 没有唱别的歌
Katrina: I'm not singing anything else.
Katrina: 我那那同学要来
Katrina: My classmate is coming.
Katrina: 那同学他
Katrina: That classmate...
Katrina: 我问他带不带吉他来
Katrina: I asked if he would bring his guitar.
Katrina: 让他上来秀一个
Katrina: Let him come and show us.
Shure: 这不就有吉他给给他了吗
Shure: We already have a guitar here for him.
Katrina: 他有自己的琴
Katrina: He has his own guitar.
Katrina: 还有电吉他
Katrina: And an electric guitar too.
Shure: 北邮这样的人我都会认识的
Shure: I know everyone at Beiyou who plays guitar.
Katrina: 另一个
Katrina: Another one.
Shure: 是我知道
Shure: I know.
Shure: 我说只要
Shure: I'm saying...
Shure: 那个会吉他的我应该是都认识
Shure: I should know everyone who plays guitar.
Shure: 他叫什么什么
Shure: What's his name?
Alice:你是哪个学院的
Alice: Which college are you in?
Shure: 我我是国际学院的
Shure: I'm in the International College.
Katrina: 你问哪一个
Katrina: Which one are you asking about?
Katrina: 男嘉宾啊
Katrina: The male guest?
Shure: 我说那个事会吉它的那个
Shure: I'm asking about the one who plays guitar.
Alice:啊什么你是你是哪个学院
Alice: Oh, which college are you from?
Shure: 国际学院
Shure: International College.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 就是那种中外合作的那个
Shure: The one that's a joint program with foreign universities.
Katrina: 那个弹吉他那个啊
Katrina: The one who plays guitar, right?
Katrina: 弹吉他那是济南大学
Katrina: He is from Jinan University.
Katrina: 然后我们俩保研认识的
Katrina: We met during our graduate school recommendations.
Katrina: 然后他在清华实习
Katrina: And then he interned at Tsinghua.
Shure: 啊嗨我以为那是北邮的呢
Shure: Oh, I thought that was at Beiyou.
Katrina: 北邮那不会
Katrina: Not at Beiyou.
Katrina: 北邮那工作狂啊
Katrina: Beiyou is full of workaholics.
Alice:你认识你的上一界吗
Alice: Do you know your senior batch?
Shure: 我认识应该
Shure: I think I do.
Katrina: 你是
Alice:我不是
Alice: No, I'm not.
Katrina: 你是
Katrina: 那他是那个女生是
Katrina: And that girl is...
Katrina: 哦
Katrina: 还是搞一首热场歌的音乐
Katrina: Or let's play some warm-up music.
Shure: 一个安静的晚上
Shure: A quiet night.
Katrina: 你能夹吗
Katrina: Can you blend in?
Katrina: 我当时跟我的室友去KTV唱这首歌
Katrina: I once went to karaoke with my roommate and sang this song.
Katrina: 可搞笑了
Katrina: It was hilarious.
Katrina: 许嵩最近在武汉开演唱会
Katrina: Xu Song recently had a concert in Wuhan.
Katrina: 这两天
Katrina: These past few days.
Katrina: 谢冰竹唱吗
Katrina: Is Xie Bingzhu singing?
Katrina: 谢冰竹
Katrina: Xie Bingzhu?
Shure: 不知道啊
Shure: I don't know.
Katrina: 把他拉上吧
Katrina: Let's get him involved.
Katrina: 不然就我俩
Katrina: Otherwise, it's just the two of us.
Katrina: 给人会笑场
Katrina: People will laugh at us.
Shure: 搞
Shure: Let's do it.
Katrina: 这要唱素颜吗
Katrina: Should we sing "Plain"?
Katrina: 但确实是一首国民歌曲
Katrina: But it's really a national favorite.
Shure: 变成情歌对唱了是吧
Shure: It turned into a love duet, right?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Katrina: 这是分男女生
Katrina: It's divided into male and female parts.
Katrina: 就是许嵩跟一个人
Katrina: It's Xu Song and someone else.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Hmm.
Shure: 我一对4唱好吧哈哈哈
Shure: I'll sing 1-on-4, alright? Haha.
Jake:可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Katrina: 揉就这面试要做什么
Katrina: So, what's the interview about?
Katrina: 明天
Katrina: Tomorrow.
Jake:呃现在做做麻薯
Jake: Uh, we're making mochi now.
Katrina: 哇每天晚上都有加餐哎
Katrina: Wow, you have extra meals every night.
Katrina: 好幸福啊
Katrina: So happy.
Jake:确实比较
Jake: It's really quite
Katrina: 麻薯好像可以放好几天哎
Katrina: Mochi seems like it can last for several days
Katrina: 哦原来麻薯是这样做的嗯
Katrina: Oh, so that's how you make mochi, hmm
Katrina: 感觉你在这几天也修炼了不少技能
Katrina: Feels like you've picked up quite a few skills these days
Jake:确实确实
Jake: Indeed, indeed
Shure: 你回去直接可以新加坡
Shure: You can go back and directly to Singapore
Shure: 新加坡
Shure: Singapore
Jake:对对对新加坡开店对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, open a shop in Singapore, right
Katrina: 新加坡开一个cake cake店
Katrina: Open a cake shop in Singapore
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Shure: 就叫EGO
Shure: Call it EGO
Katrina: EGO cake
Jake:哈哈哈EGO cake可以可以可以
Jake: Hahaha, EGO cake, sounds good, sounds good
Jake:EGO Bakery可以可以
Jake: EGO Bakery, sounds good
Jake:然后所有加热材料都是显卡
Jake: And all the heating materials are graphics cards
Jake:就主打显卡
Jake: Focusing on graphics cards
Katrina: 一个蛋糕换一张显卡
Katrina: Trade a cake for a graphics card
Katrina: 一个一个显卡换一张蛋糕
Katrina: Trade a graphics card for a cake
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Jake:这个可以这个可以
Jake: This is good, this is good
Jake:这个我喜欢我靠
Jake: I like this, oh my
Katrina: 定一下
Katrina: Make a decision
Jake:哎呀我去
Jake: Oh my gosh
Katrina: 你最拿手的吧
Katrina: This is your specialty, right
Katrina: 就是不用看谱的
Katrina: You don't even need to look at the sheet music
Katrina: 你有推荐不
Katrina: Do you have any recommendations
Katrina: 稍微热热场子
Katrina: Warm up the atmosphere a bit
Katrina: 呃那个你要跳舞吗
Katrina: Uh, do you want to dance
Katrina: 其实人多唱应该还行
Katrina: Actually, it's fine if everyone sings together
Katrina: 能唱上去吗
Katrina: Can you hit the notes
Shure: 女朋友会易眼前
Shure: Your girlfriend will appear
Shure: 咦又唱这个破歌
Shure: Oh, singing this song again
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina: 行那换一个
Katrina: Okay, let's change it then
Shure: 没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no
Alice:你女朋友会来吗
Alice: Is your girlfriend coming
Shure: 会吧应该
Shure: Should be
Katrina: 那把她喊上来一起唱
Katrina: Then call her up to sing together
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahaha
Shure: 别别别
Shure: No, no, no
Katrina: 你女朋友是爱人吗
Katrina: Is your girlfriend your lover?
Katrina: 你女朋友是爱人
Katrina: Your girlfriend is your lover.
Shure: 我也是爱人
Shure: I'm also a lover.
Shure: 就我意的浓度不高你知道吗
Shure: But my concentration isn't high, you know?
Katrina: 找你了
Katrina: Found you.
Katrina: 你们东北爱人是这样
Katrina: You Northeasterners call lovers like this.
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hello?
Shure: 没事他那个去
Shure: It's okay, he went to...
Shure: 卫卫生那什么的
Shure: the bathroom or something.
Shure: 啊好
Shure: Ah, okay.
Shure: 那个杨老板
Shure: Hey, Jake.
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah?
Shure: 把那个手机号给尼蔻斯发一下呗
Shure: Send Nicous that phone number, will you?
Shure: 路亚的
Shure: Lua's number.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Shure: 把路亚的手机号给那个那谁发一下
Shure: Send Lua's phone number to, you know, that person.
Jake:手机号啊
Jake: The phone number?
Shure: 他联系不到路亚现在
Shure: He can't get in touch with Lua right now.
Jake:OK行
Jake: OK, got it.
Shure: 好
Shure: Good.
Katrina: 不行
Katrina: No way.
Katrina: 不能唱情歌
Katrina: Can't sing love songs.
Katrina: 为什么
Katrina: Why?
Shure: 咋还在这
Shure: Why are you still here?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 唱素颜多那个
Katrina: Singing "Plain Face" is so...
Katrina: 我也是被图书馆30秒弄过的人
Katrina: I was also caught by the library for 30 seconds.
Katrina: 好吧不能这样
Katrina: Alright, can't do this.
Katrina: 换一首嗨一点的
Katrina: Let's switch to a more lively song.
Katrina: 刚刚有听到一首歌陶哲比较简单的歌
Katrina: Just heard a simple song by David Tao.
Katrina: 比较温馨的一首歌
Katrina: It's a very warm song.
Katrina: 不知道难不难
Katrina: Not sure if it's hard.
Katrina: 你可以听一下
Katrina: You can listen to it.
Shure: 绿色的
Shure: The green one.
Katrina: 哎
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina: 之前有一首哦
Katrina: There was one before.
Katrina: 但是没看到
Katrina: But I didn't see it.
Katrina: 是一个英文歌的
Katrina: It was an English song.
Katrina: 这一首比较和平的全世界会唱
Katrina: This one is peaceful, everyone in the world can sing it.
Katrina: 世界地球日是唱什么歌我想唱一句试试
Katrina: What song do people sing on Earth Day? I want to try singing a line.
Katrina: 刚打开小红书就刷到了南阳理工大学
Katrina: I just opened Xiaohongshu and saw Nanyang Technological University.
Katrina: 满足了我对大学的一切想象
Katrina: It fulfilled all my imaginations about university.
Shure: 我给谢彬竹拿把伞下雨了
Shure: I'll get a umbrella for Xie Binzhu, it's raining.
Katrina: 下雨了吗
Katrina: Is it raining?
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 来抱着他吧
Shure: Come, hold him.
Katrina: 我装一下我装一下
Katrina: I'll pretend, I'll pretend.
Shure: 对
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 我要摆拍了你赶紧走吧
Katrina: I'm gonna pose, you better go.
Shure: 你装个逼 好的
Shure: Just act cool, alright.
Katrina: 啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Nicous: 不是 刚刚
Nicous: No, just now...
Shure: 你给他拿把伞啊
Shure: You got him an umbrella, right?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake:拿把伞干嘛
Jake: Why did you get an umbrella?
Shure: 他他要把伞
Shure: He, he wanted an umbrella.
Nicous: 刚刚在
Nicous: Just now...
Nicous: 她 没理我
Nicous: She ignored me.
Jake:没理你你他妈找我还去咖啡厅干嘛
Jake: She ignored you? Then why the hell are you asking me to go to a cafe?
Jake:你干嘛啊
Jake: What are you doing?
Nicous: 啊
Nicous: Huh?
Jake:啊
Jake: Huh?
Nicous: 怎么
Nicous: What?
Jake:没他没理你
Jake: She ignored you.
Jake:你过来找我
Jake: Then you come to me.
Nicous: 我过来准备打电话的
Nicous: I came here to make a call.
Shure: 非常快乐的
Shure: It's really fun.
Shure: 有一首歌叫做水手公园
Shure: There's a song called Sailor Park.
Katrina: 没听过
Katrina: Never heard of it.
Katrina: 要不就唱NEW BOY
Katrina: How about we sing NEW BOY?
Shure: 行那就NEW BOY
Shure: Sure, let's do NEW BOY.
Katrina: 试一下
Katrina: Let's try it.
Katrina: 唱唯一哈
Katrina: Sing The Only one.
Katrina: 北京民谣摇滚第九名
Katrina: Beijing folk rock, ninth place.
Katrina: 行行行你弹吧
Katrina: Alright, alright, you play.
Shure: 我忘了词了
Shure: I forgot the lyrics.
Katrina: 这调调是高了还是低
Katrina: Is this tune too high or too low?
Katrina: 感觉好跑调啊我
Katrina: I feel like I'm off-key.
Shure: 有点难唱说实话
Shure: It's a bit hard to sing, to be honest.
Katrina: 嗯 真的是
Katrina: Yeah, it really is.
Shure: 就最不难唱
Shure: It's the easiest to sing.
Shure: 你你你要跳舞吗
Shure: Do you, do you, do you want to dance?
Shure: 怎么样 这个唱能吗
Shure: How about it? Can you sing this?
Katrina: 可以吧这首歌好老好老
Katrina: I think so. This song is really old, really old.
Katrina: 你咋听你听听应该都能成唱
Katrina: If you listen to it, you should be able to sing it.
Shure: 哎你还有没有什么其他想法
Shure: Hey, do you have any other ideas?
Shure: perfect是吧咱又开始唱perfect
Shure: Perfect, right? Should we start with "Perfect"?
Katrina: 唱点
Katrina: Sing something.
Katrina: 开场开场爱上咱
Katrina: Start with "In Love with Us".
Katrina: 计划几首
Katrina: How many songs are planned?
Katrina: 这个这个是替代那个跳舞的
Katrina: This one replaces the dancing.
Katrina: 就是还是晚上的活动
Katrina: It's still an evening activity.
Shure: 我们就抛砖引玉
Shure: We just give a little teaser.
Shure: 如果
Shure: If...
Katrina: 就是让他们跟他们的朋友说一下
Katrina: Just let them tell their friends.
Katrina: 也可以上来唱歌
Katrina: They can also come up and sing.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 可以换BISS
Shure: We can switch to BISS.
Katrina: 我们可以搞个
Katrina: We can prepare...
Katrina: 准备个两手
Katrina: Prepare two songs.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 哎呀这怎么夹一口
Shure: Oh man, how do I get a bite?
Shure: 他夹不紧
Shure: It doesn't hold tight.
Katrina: 我觉得这首好适合晚上弹吉他唱
Katrina: I think this song is perfect for playing guitar and singing at night.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 这可以当第二首
Katrina: This can be the second song.
Katrina: 我感觉路亚应该也可以
Katrina: I think Loya can do it too.
Katrina: 大家都可以唱吧我觉得
Katrina: I think everyone can sing it.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina: 这行这可以当第二首
Katrina: This works, this can be the second song.
Katrina: 开场什么的
Katrina: For the opening or something.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 这个难吗你弹
Katrina: Is this hard for you to play?
Shure: 可以弹 能弹
Shure: I can play it. I can.
Katrina: 呃开场好玩一点
Katrina: Uh, let's make the opening a bit more fun.
Katrina: 呃叫什么来着
Katrina: Uh, what's it called again?
Katrina: 找自己听过吗
Katrina: "Find Yourself", have you heard it?
Katrina: 可以试试
Katrina: We can try it.
Katrina: 啊这好像有点难呃
Katrina: Ah, this seems a bit hard, uh.
Shure: 我想起来了
Shure: I remember now.
Shure: 但吉他好像很难
Shure: But playing the guitar seems really hard.
Shure: 咱俩咱俩呱然后
Shure: You and I, we can... and then...
Katrina: 你搜一下
Katrina: You should look it up.
Shure: 就是谈陶喆
Shure: It's about talking with David Tao.
Shure: 就是有点
Shure: It's kind of...
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 去逃避
Shure: To escape.
Shure: 这个好简单啊
Shure: This is so easy.
Katrina: 很简单吗
Katrina: Is it really easy?
Shure: 我不知道这谱子是太简单还是怎么着
Shure: I don't know if the sheet music is just too easy or what.
Katrina: 这唱不了
Katrina: I can't sing this.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 不能用纯吉他来伴奏
Katrina: You can't just use a guitar to accompany this.
Shure: 哎 想想
Shure: Hey, think about it.
Katrina: 摇滚的要么就唱张璇
Katrina: For rock, you could sing something by Zhang Xuan.
Katrina: 也不算吧
Katrina: Or not, maybe.
Shure: 我的宝贝宝贝
Shure: My baby, baby.
Katrina: 这个好适合吉他唱
Katrina: This one is great for singing with a guitar.
Katrina: 眼睛像哄睡
Katrina: It's like a lullaby.
Shure: 呵我还唱过这个
Shure: Haha, I've even sung this one before.
Katrina: 真的吗这这也好听
Katrina: Really? This one sounds nice too.
Shure: 不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 我说那个张璇那个宝贝
Shure: I mean the one by Zhang Xuan, "Baby."
Katrina: 嗯这很适合唱给女朋友听啊
Katrina: Hmm, this one is perfect to sing to your girlfriend.
Katrina: 要不唱告告五人的
Katrina: How about singing something by Accusefive?
Katrina: 适合用吉他吗
Katrina: Is it good with a guitar?
Shure: 哎哪去吧
Shure: Hey, where did it go?
Shure: 那个去哪了
Shure: Where did that go?
Shure: 啊这个
Shure: Ah, this one.
Katrina: 怎么啦我就是把嗓子给吃了
Katrina: What's up? I just kind of lost my voice.
Katrina: 你家唱歌就是会自动变人家是变夹
Katrina: When you sing, your voice automatically changes, like...
Katrina: 你是
Katrina: You are...
Shure: 我什么都会变
Shure: I can change to anything.
Shure: 特别油的那种
Shure: Especially that greasy kind.
Katrina: 哎哟 你好愁啊
Katrina: Oh my, you seem so worried.
Katrina: 还给自己加的特效呢
Katrina: You even added special effects for yourself.
Shure: 特别特别油的最后一幕
Shure: Especially the very last scene, it's super greasy.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha.
Shure: 可多特别特别油的
Shure: There are so many super greasy ones.
Katrina: 哎这个泪桥当时有那个街头弹唱吧
Katrina: Hey, at "Tear Bridge," there was a street performance, right?
Shure: 泪桥
Shure: Tear Bridge
Katrina: 但这个好一啊
Katrina: But this one's really good
Katrina: 唱得
Katrina: The singing
Katrina: 我给你看我当时就是听那个
Katrina: Let me show you, I was just listening to that
Katrina: 什么嗯嗯嗯
Katrina: What, um, um, um
Katrina: 泪桥 有一阵子火
Katrina: Tear Bridge was popular for a while
Katrina: 啊哈哈哈
Katrina: Ahahaha
Katrina: 你真不像个IE人素质
Katrina: You don't really seem like an IE person with that attitude
Shure: 那我切试一眼试一眼
Shure: Well, let me give it a try
Katrina: 哎呀不知道他用的是哪个谱子
Katrina: Oh, I don't know which version he's using
Katrina: 就是调调是这样 女生版很好听
Katrina: The tune goes like this, the female version is really nice
Katrina: 你搜女生版的
Katrina: Look up the female version
Katrina: 我给你听伍佰的原唱是什么样的
Katrina: I'll let you hear how the original by Wu Bai sounds
Shure: 我找一下这个调
Shure: Let me find this tune
Shure: 来 唱这个
Shure: Come on, sing this
Shure: 你先把这个关了
Shure: Turn this off first
Shure: 你在放刚刚那个
Shure: Play the one from before
Shure: 这个
Shure: This one
Katrina: 你能听出这个音啊
Katrina: Can you hear this note?
Shure: 对吧
Shure: Right?
Katrina: 嗯你自己调啦等
Katrina: Yeah, you adjust it yourself then
Katrina: 他这是不是改编吧
Katrina: Did he adapt this?
Shure: 嗯差不多
Shure: Pretty much
Katrina: 这个也是一抹神曲
Katrina: This is also a god-tier song
Shure: 是的
Shure: It is
Katrina: 当然是
Katrina: Of course it is
Shure: 随便 想唱什么什么
Shure: Whatever, sing whatever you want
Katrina: 这难吗
Katrina: Is this hard?
Shure: 不难
Shure: Not hard
Katrina: 这你这也不能我唱你也得唱
Katrina: You can't just let me sing, you have to sing too
Katrina: 我不敢一个人独唱
Katrina: I don't dare to sing solo
Shure: 那有什么不敢的
Shure: What's there to be afraid of?
Shure: 小小养乐多
Shure: Little Yakult
Shure: 肠道大活力
Shure: Big digestive boost
Shure: 腿麻了哦靠
Shure: My leg is numb, oh damn
Shure: 哦靠哦靠哦靠
Shure: Oh damn, oh damn, oh damn
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 我们egou life就是白兰英来了
Shure: Our egou life, it's Bairan coming
Shure: 哎呦卧槽
Shure: Oh, crap
Shure: 人类为什么会腿吗
Shure: Why do humans get numb legs?
Shure: 我拿一下
Shure: Let me grab that.
Shure: 哎哟
Shure: Ouch.
Katrina: 就是爱你好像也挺适合弹唱的
Katrina: I think you’d be great at singing and playing "I Love You".
Katrina: 因为我看现场他就自己弹
Katrina: Because I saw him do it live by himself.
Shure: 谁
Shure: Who?
Katrina: 陶喆的就是爱你
Katrina: David Tao’s "I Love You".
Katrina: 我我我之前练这吉他我就半途而废
Katrina: I, I, I gave up practicing the guitar halfway through.
Katrina: 是因为我老按不紧
Katrina: Because I couldn’t press the strings hard enough.
Shure: 有可能能琴有关系
Shure: Maybe it’s the guitar.
Shure: 我总感觉这个镜子照人会偏高
Shure: I always feel like this mirror makes people look taller.
Katrina: 真的吗
Katrina: Really?
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina: 那我觉得我还挺好看的
Katrina: Well, I think I look pretty good in it.
Katrina: 原来是假的
Katrina: So, it’s fake?
Shure: 我靠真的
Shure: Seriously, it’s true.
Shure: 他会把别人照高好多
Shure: It makes everyone look much taller.
Shure: 就我这个头发永远是在在那是
Shure: My hair is always at that level.
Shure: 你看哦
Shure: Look.
Katrina: 是假这什么原理啊
Katrina: How does that work?
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don’t know.
Katrina: 看唯一怎么唱
Katrina: Let’s see how the only one sings.
Shure: 就非得唱一些伊某小曲的
Shure: Do we have to sing some folk tune?
Katrina: 焰火
Katrina: Fireworks.
Katrina: 假装吉他
Katrina: Pretend guitar.
Katrina: 这能用这没法用吉他弹出来
Katrina: You can’t really play this on the guitar.
Katrina: 然后后面背景音乐很那个
Katrina: And the background music is really...
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh man.
Shure: 本来说今天晚上一定要把论文写完
Shure: I was supposed to finish my thesis tonight.
Shure: 我现在好困
Shure: Now I’m so sleepy.
Shure: 完了
Shure: This is bad.
Katrina: 先泡咖啡
Katrina: Make some coffee first.
Shure: 现在
Shure: Now?
Shure: 弄死我得了
Shure: It’ll kill me.
Shure: 我们先
Shure: Let’s first...
Shure: 先把这个明天的定下来
Shure: Let’s first finalize tomorrow’s stuff.
Shure: 然后再再
Shure: Then we can...
Shure: 随便弹
Shure: Play freely.
Katrina: 就是第一首perfect应该没问题
Katrina: The first song, "Perfect", should be fine.
Shure: 真的perfect
Shure: Truly perfect.
Katrina: 嗯p嗯
Katrina: Um, p, um
Shure: pp一下吧没问题
Shure: Just p, it's fine.
Katrina: 泪桥估计嗯最好选大家都会的
Katrina: I guess for "Tears Bridge," it's best to choose what everyone knows.
Katrina: 泪桥估计比较不是小众
Katrina: I guess "Tears Bridge" is not that niche.
Shure: 稍微冷门一点点
Shure: A bit more obscure.
Katrina: 嗯冷门一点
Katrina: Yes, a bit more obscure.
Shure: 嗨 一点的都有什么曲子
Shure: What are some of the more obscure songs?
Katrina: 嗯你要是一一点的歌的话
Katrina: If you're looking for more obscure songs...
Katrina: 唯一跟唯一大家也会点
Katrina: "Only" and "Perfect," people know them too.
Katrina: 唯一和perfect二选一
Katrina: "Only" and "Perfect," pick one of the two.
Katrina: 欢快一点的
Katrina: Something more cheerful.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 我现在在思考
Shure: I'm thinking right now.
Shure: 定下歌曲
Shure: Deciding on the song.
Jake:自己作词
Jake: Write your own lyrics.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Katrina: 你就唱草履虫拉倒吧
Katrina: Just sing "Paramecium," and be done with it.
Jake:你把词写了让人唱
Jake: You write the lyrics and let someone else sing.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 这是什么
Katrina: What is this?
Alice:狂犬疫苗是挺疼的
Alice: Rabies vaccine really hurts.
Jake:这是我刚刚
Jake: This is something I just...
Katrina: 然后看看看看刚
Katrina: Then, look, look, look, just...
Jake:学习的
Jake: ...learned.
Tasha:老师做的
Tasha: The teacher made it.
Tasha:杨老师做的
Tasha: Mr. Yang made it.
Jake:学习的
Jake: ...learned.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Tasha:你有没有发现你没有带筷子上来
Tasha: Did you realize you didn't bring chopsticks up?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Tasha:大家怎么吃啊
Tasha: How's everyone going to eat?
Katrina: 这已经做好了
Katrina: It's already done.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 好厉害啊
Katrina: Amazing.
Katrina: 这东西做的很快吗居然
Katrina: Did you make this really fast?
Jake:这东西做的我馋死了
Jake: This thing looks so delicious.
Jake:我靠满手的这个
Jake: My hands are full of this...
Shure: 面
Shure: Dough.
Jake:黏的
Jake: ...sticky stuff.
Jake:可粘了洗了10分钟的手
Jake: It's so sticky, I've been washing my hands for 10 minutes.
Jake:他要是 哎露西呢
Jake: Where is Lucia?
Tasha:我们就坐在这是吗
Tasha: Are we just sitting here?
Jake:我们就坐在这
Jake: Yeah, we'll just sit here.
Tasha:你要不要把大垫子拖出来
Tasha: Do you want to pull out the big cushion?
Jake:大垫子
Jake: The big cushion?
Shure: 就把那个
Shure: Just that one.
Jake:哦你的那个大垫子也用不着吧
Jake: Oh, we don't need the big cushion, right?
Jake:用不着用不着
Jake: We don't need it.
Jake:就这个足够了
Jake: This is enough.
Katrina: 那就一起讨论呗
Katrina: Let's just discuss it together.
Shure: 露西亚你会唱是吧
Shure: Lucia, you can sing, right?
Katrina: 他不是露西亚
Katrina: He's not Lucia.
Katrina: 他是微微
Katrina: He's Weiwei.
Jake:你完了
Jake: You're done for.
Shure: 你叫什么露西亚
Shure: Why did you call him Lucia?
Katrina: 我是子轩
Katrina: I'm Zixuan.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我是子轩
Katrina: Haha, I'm Zixuan.
Jake:子轩好 你好子轩
Jake: Zixuan, nice to meet you.
Tasha:你完了
Tasha: You're done for.
Jake:你好子轩
Jake: Hello, Zixuan.
Jake:不 不 不
Jake: No, no, no.
Katrina: 他是露西亚我是
Katrina: He is Lucia, I am...
Tasha:我叫什么
Tasha: What is my name?
Jake:我是露西亚
Jake: I am Lucia.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Shure: 你你叫塔莎
Shure: No, you are Tasha.
Jake:我叫什么
Jake: What is my name?
Jake:我叫露西亚
Jake: I am Lucia.
Shure: 你叫Jing Kang
Shure: Your name is Jing Kang.
Jake:我靠什么东西
Jake: What the heck?
Tasha:他就只能叫他有他
Tasha: He can only call himself that.
Tasha:他有英文名吗
Tasha: Does he have an English name?
Shure: Jing Kang
Shure: Jing Kang.
Tasha:你有英文名吗
Tasha: Do you have an English name?
Jake:我可以有
Jake: I could have one.
Jake:给给一个
Jake: Give me one.
Shure: JK young
Shure: JK Young.
Tasha:哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:我靠
Jake: What the heck?
Shure: number seven JKyoung
Shure: Number seven JKyoung
Jake:为什么是seven啊
Jake: Why number seven?
Shure: 没有就是脑袋里面第一个蹦的
Shure: No reason, it was just the first thing that popped into my head.
Shure: 就是number seven
Shure: Just number seven.
Shure: 韦世豪哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Wei Shihao, hahaha.
Shure: 什么你不知道这个梗吗
Shure: What, you don't get this joke?
Jake:再说一遍
Jake: Say it again.
Shure: number seven韦世豪
Shure: Number seven Wei Shihao.
Jake:韦世豪我知道了啊
Jake: Wei Shihao, I got it.
Shure: 然后哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: And then, hahaha.
Jake:我上回看到踢球了
Jake: I saw him playing soccer last time.
Jake:在那个中国队踢平新加坡
Jake: In that match where China tied with Singapore.
Jake:逼平新加坡啊
Jake: They forced a draw with Singapore.
Jake:对中国国足
Jake: The Chinese national soccer team.
Jake:逼平新家坡
Jake: Forced a draw with Singapore.
Shure: 想想塔莎
Shure: Think about it, Tasha.
Tasha:干嘛
Tasha: What's up?
Katrina: 想一首大家都会的欢快的歌
Katrina: Think of a cheerful song that everyone knows.
Shure: 你们也可以唱你家乡的歌
Shure: You can also sing a song from your hometown.
Tasha:那必须要唱那种EMO神曲
Tasha: Then it has to be an EMO anthem.
Katrina: EMO选了一个
Katrina: EMO, pick one.
Katrina: 那个安静一点
Katrina: Something quieter.
Katrina: 要么唯一
Katrina: Or "The Only One."
Katrina: 要么就那个perfect
Katrina: Or "Perfect."
Katrina: 就黄老板那个
Katrina: You know, by Ed Sheeran.
Katrina: 应该这个
Katrina: Maybe that one.
Katrina: 这两个大家都比较熟吧
Katrina: These two are quite familiar to everyone.
Shure: 那唱那什么吧
Shure: Then let's sing that one.
Shure: 唱卡丘莎
Shure: Let's sing "Katyusha."
Shure: 你家乡的小曲
Shure: Your hometown's little tune.
Shure: 想想动动你聪明的小脑瓜
Shure: Come on, use your clever little brain.
Katrina: 看看你刚刚那个new boy
Katrina: Look at that new boy you mentioned.
Katrina: 咱俩唱太难听了
Katrina: The two of us singing sounded awful.
Shure: 把把我去了
Shure: Just leave me out of it.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 咱俩唱太难听
Katrina: The two of us singing sounded awful.
Shure: 不管把我去开
Shure: No matter what, leave me out of it.
Tasha:他不难听
Tasha: It's not awful.
Tasha:是这个意思吗
Tasha: Is that what you mean?
Shure: 你会唱new boy
Shure: Do you know how to sing "New Boy"?
Shure: 听过吗
Shure: Have you heard of it?
Shure: 是呀哈哈哈
Shure: Yeah, haha.
Katrina: 这可这人多一点
Katrina: There are more people here.
Shure: 你觉得唱歌如何
Shure: How do you think the singing was?
Tasha:非常不好听
Tasha: It was really bad.
Shure: 那我们唱哪首歌
Shure: Which song should we sing?
Shure: 我们唱那首西城男孩 吧
Shure: Let's sing that Westlife song.
Shure: 好这个我不会弹
Shure: Well, I can't play this one.
Katrina: 这个太难了他明白
Katrina: This one is too hard, he gets it.
Katrina: 这不嗨呀我以为这个摇滚的会嗨一点
Katrina: This isn't upbeat, I thought this rock song would be more exciting.
Shure: 这根本就不可以
Shure: This just won't work.
Shure: 用一把木的吉他给他
Shure: Give him an acoustic guitar.
Shure: 就是那种欢快跳脱
Shure: 水手
Shure: Sailor.
Shure: 公园
Shure: Park.
Shure: 这个很跳脱
Katrina: 哎小陈夏天呢
Katrina: Hey, where's Chen in the summer?
Katrina: 叫什么歌来着
Katrina: What's the name of the song again?
Shure: 水手公园那个旮旯乐队
Shure: Sailor Park by that corner band.
Jake:不唱英文真听不出来
Jake: You can't tell when it's not in English.
Shure: 哈哈确实哈哈
Shure: Haha, exactly, haha.
Katrina: 这能用吉他弹出来吗
Katrina: Can this be played on guitar?
Shure: 可以吧
Shure: Probably.
Shure: 水手公园
Shure: Sailor Park.
Shure: 不行就是新造的人好吧
Shure: No, it's just new people, okay?
Jake:可以迎接他们一下
Jake: We can welcome them.
Jake:把他们拐到一个小边上
Jake: Lead them to a small corner.
Katrina: 海域恋你听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard of Sea Love?
Katrina: 海域恋也行
Katrina: Sea Love is good too.
Shure: 可以试试明天
Shure: We can try it tomorrow.
Katrina: 那就这个开场
Katrina: Let's open with that one.
Katrina: 这个就大家一起唱
Katrina: Everyone can sing along.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Katrina: 这听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard of this?
Katrina: 孙燕姿的第一天
Katrina: Stefanie Sun's "First Day".
Shure: 第一天
Shure: First Day.
Shure: 想起来第一次告白
Shure: Reminds me of the first confession.
Shure: 心燥的人
Shure: Restless people.
Katrina: 还下雨嘞这个人听过吗
Katrina: It's raining, have you heard of this person?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Shure: 塔莎给的议建
Shure: The suggestion from Tasha
Shure: 这听过了
Shure: We've heard this before.
Katrina: 感觉这歌挺好唱
Katrina: Feels like this song is pretty easy to sing.
Katrina: 试一下不
Katrina: Wanna give it a try?
Jake:这得一群人一起唱然后在啊啊啊
Jake: This one's gotta be sung by a group, and then go like "ah ah ah."
Shure: 周楚除三害
Shure: Zhou Chu Eliminates the Three Evils.
Shure: 知道这个电影吗
Shure: Know this movie?
Katrina: 哦知道知道
Katrina: Oh, I know it.
Katrina: 但我没看
Katrina: But I haven't seen it.
Shure: 就是中间那个
Shure: It's that one...
Shure: 就是前段时间特别火的那个
Shure: The one that was super popular a while ago.
Shure: 棒棒棒挨个打死
Shure: Everyone gets hit one by one.
Shure: 好吧 那得想想
Shure: Alright, let me think about it.
Shure: 我们我知道了
Shure: I know now.
Shure: 开心超人听过吗
Shure: Have you heard of Happy Superman?
Katrina: 我有时候会
Katrina: Sometimes.
Katrina: 手机应该听过
Katrina: Probably heard it on my phone.
Katrina: 应该 听过
Katrina: Probably heard it.
Tasha:哦我知道那个
Tasha: Oh, I know that one.
Shure: 听过吗这首歌
Shure: Have you heard this song?
Katrina: 门口吗 3
Katrina: At the door? 3
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:人类都记住了
Jake: Everyone remembers it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 你们的朋友会唱歌吗
Katrina: Can your friends sing?
Jake:就就就这种唱法
Jake: Like this kind of singing.
Katrina: 到时候反正他有音响
Katrina: Anyway, he has speakers.
Katrina: 直接那个呗
Katrina: Just do it directly.
Katrina: 唱歌就搞个话筒
Katrina: Just get a microphone for singing.
Katrina: 然后唱歌也可以获得获得
Katrina: And then you can sing and get...
Alice:我会骑牛
Alice: I can ride a bull.
Alice:正威的唱法
Alice: Zheng Wei's singing style.
Shure: 蛋黄的长裙
Shure: Egg yolk-colored dress.
Shure: 蓬松的头发
Shure: Fluffy hair.
Alice:确实
Alice: Indeed.
Katrina: 一首就开场欢快一点
Katrina: One song to start off lively.
Katrina: 一首就是适合晚上的慢悠悠的那种
Katrina: And one that's slow and suitable for the night.
Katrina: 开场的话有听这个
Katrina: For the opening, have you heard this one?
Katrina: 开心超人你听过吗
Katrina: Have you heard of Happy Heroes?
Katrina: 哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Nicous: 结尾想好
Nicous: Think of an ending
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:可拉倒吧
Jake: Oh, come on
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 可以整的
Shure: We can do it
Jake:插点电插点电
Jake: Plug it in, plug it in
Shure: 给我来一个宝
Shure: Give me a power bank
Tasha:我需要一个充电宝
Tasha: I need a power bank
Shure: 给我来个宝
Shure: Give me a power bank
Shure: 这首歌叫啥来着
Shure: What's this song called?
Tasha:好像就叫朋友吧
Tasha: I think it's called "Friend"
Shure: 啊老男孩
Shure: Oh, "Old Boy"
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahaha
Katrina: 还没唱难忘今宵呢
Katrina: We haven't sung "Unforgettable Tonight" yet
Katrina: 难忘今宵哎
Katrina: "Unforgettable Tonight"
Katrina: 我觉得可以
Katrina: I think it's good
Nicous: 这个好
Nicous: This one is good
Lucia:每人唱一句
Lucia: Everyone sings a line
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 上春山是吧
Shure: On Spring Mountain, right?
Tasha:然后
Tasha: Then
Lucia:然后再大合唱了
Lucia: Then we'll have a big chorus
Katrina: 也行也行
Katrina: That works, that works
Katrina: 每人唱一句工作量就小一点
Katrina: If everyone sings a line, it's less work
Lucia:17
Lucia: 17
Jake:17没事多很多
Jake: 17 is fine, a lot more
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Katrina: 对但你可以拿双筷子吗
Katrina: Yeah, but can you grab a pair of chopsticks?
Tasha:筷子呢
Tasha: Where are the chopsticks?
Shure: 哦我需要个宝
Shure: Oh, I need a power bank
Jake:你给你一个宝
Jake: Here's a power bank for you
Shure: 谢谢
Shure: Thanks
Katrina: 海遇恋好像是那个谁的
Katrina: "Sea Encounter Love" seems to be from someone
Katrina: 很老的一首歌
Katrina: It's a very old song
Katrina: 你们有推荐的吗
Katrina: Do you have any recommendations?
Katrina: 你把那几个弹给他们听一遍呗
Katrina: Play those few for them
Katrina: 开心超人
Katrina: Happy Heroes
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 大家
Shure: Everyone
Shure: 听过开心超人吗
Shure: Have you heard of Happy Heroes?
Lucia:no
Lucia: No
Lucia:那个再见吧妈妈吗
Lucia: Is that "Goodbye Mom"?
Shure: 什么是快乐星球
Shure: What is Happy Planet?
Katrina: 开心超人弹
Katrina: Happy Heroes song
Jake:每人领一个
Jake: Everyone gets one
Lucia:我洗个手
Lucia: I'll wash my hands
Lucia:我刚从那个啥医院回来
Lucia: I just got back from the hospital
Lucia:不敢直接接触吃的
Lucia: I don't want to touch food directly
Katrina: 尝尝
Katrina: Try it
Katrina: 你这是开心超人的歌吗
Katrina: Is this the Happy Heroes song?
Shure: 阿里嘎多
Shure: Arigato
Shure: 啊是的
Shure: Ah, yes
Katrina: 怎么缠着悲悲伤的感觉
Katrina: Why does it feel sad?
Shure: 我可以把
Shure: I can...
Tasha:哎哎
Tasha: Hey hey
Katrina: 要怎么吃
Katrina: How to eat this?
Tasha:还先蘸这个再蘸这个
Tasha: You dip it in this and then in that
Nicous: 这么讲究
Nicous: So particular
Shure: 可是我刚刚舔过来的
Shure: But I just licked it
Katrina: 哈哈你算了
Katrina: Haha, never mind
Nicous: 这是这叫什么 嗯
Nicous: What's this called? Hmm
Tasha:蘸蘸汤
Tasha: Dip dip soup
Shure: 有毒
Shure: It's poison
Tasha:蘸蘸再蘸一蘸啊
Tasha: Dip it, then dip it again
Tasha:然后蘸蘸这个
Tasha: And then dip it in this
Shure: 唉呀妈
Shure: Oh my
Shure: 有毒有毒
Shure: It's poison, it's poison
Nicous: 哦靠这么好吃
Nicous: Oh wow, it's so delicious
Katrina: 黏黏的
Katrina: It's sticky
Shure: 我没蘸东西
Shure: I didn't dip it in anything
Katrina: 我太屌了
Katrina: I'm awesome
Shure: 我操
Shure: Damn
Katrina: 香
Katrina: Fragrant
Alice:轩
Alice: Xuan
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Mm
Shure: 轩啊
Shure: Xuan
Katrina: 轩啊
Katrina: Xuan
Jake:来
Jake: Come on
Lucia:谢谢嗯嗯
Lucia: Thanks, mm-hmm.
Lucia:年糕吗
Lucia: Is this rice cake?
Alice:麻薯
Alice: It's mochi.
Jake:看看这个店
Jake: Take a look at this shop.
Lucia:这两个是什么味
Lucia: What flavors are these two?
Lucia:碗都要给我蘸走了
Lucia: The bowl is almost dipped away by me.
Katrina: 开心往前飞
Katrina: Happiness flies forward.
Katrina: 快点
Katrina: Hurry up!
Lucia:每次发挥都这么不稳定
Lucia: Every time my performance is so unstable.
Nicous: 对
Nicous: Right.
Lucia:我是不是跟奶油有什么仇啊
Lucia: Do I have a grudge against cream or something?
Shure: 多少多少学费
Shure: How much is the tuition?
Tasha: 啊什么
Tasha: What?
Shure: 最重要
Shure: It's the most important.
Tasha:什么不要学费
Tasha: What? There's no tuition?
Lucia:我好像跟奶油有仇似的
Lucia: It's like I have a grudge against cream.
Lucia:有你去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: If you go to places with many Chinese students, there definitely will be.
Tasha:他说有没有竞争力
Tasha: He asked if there's competitiveness.
Lucia:有竞争力啊
Lucia: There is competitiveness.
Lucia:就是去中国留学生多的地方肯定有
Lucia: It's just that if you go to places with many Chinese students, there definitely will be.
Tasha:那不是有市场吗
Tasha: Isn't that a market then?
Lucia:对
Lucia: Right.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Tasha:不是我的意思是啊
Tasha: No, what I mean is...
Jake:这也没多少
Jake: This isn't much.
Tasha:利润很大
Tasha: The profit is huge.
Tasha:去办一个
Tasha: Go and set one up.
Tasha:开家店
Tasha: Open a shop.
Lucia:这水应该可以喝吧
Lucia: This water should be drinkable, right?
Lucia:医生让我多喝点水哦
Lucia: The doctor told me to drink more water.
Lucia:我想申请一下这疫苗能报销吗
Lucia: I want to apply for reimbursement for this vaccine.
Jake:呃能报能报
Jake: Uh, it can be reimbursed, it can be reimbursed.
Jake:报了
Jake: It's reimbursed.
Lucia:好谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thank you, thank you.
Shure: 这
Shure: This...
Lucia:我甚至期待项目结束还得再打两针
Lucia: I even expect to get two more shots after the project ends.
Jake:啊行行
Jake: Ah, okay, okay.
Tasha:没有去新疆学啊
Tasha: Didn't you go to learn in Xinjiang?
Tasha:不是这个不是在哪里学
Tasha: No, it's not about where you learn.
Tasha:这个没有在哪学
Tasha: It's not about where you learn.
Shure: 这不是假的吗
Shure: Isn't this fake?
Shure: 哎呦你这不听
Shure: Hey, you're not listening.
Lucia:万一我今天晚上发烧了的话
Lucia: What if I get a fever tonight?
Lucia:哈哈好
Lucia: Haha, okay.
Jake:好待会可以
Jake: Alright, we can do it later.
Lucia:请大家那个
Lucia: Can everyone please...
Lucia:帮我冻点冰水哈哈哈
Lucia: Help me freeze some ice water, hahaha.
Lucia:没有没有应该不会就
Lucia: No, no, it probably won't happen.
Tasha:那不是假的吗
Tasha: Isn't that fake?
Jake:看看你你伤
Jake: Look at you, you're hurt.
Nicous: 不是我以为都是真的只有那个
Nicous: No, I thought everything was real, only that...
Lucia:这个就是他
Lucia: This is just him...
Nicous: 第二点就是只有只有开头第二点假的
Nicous: The second point is only, only the beginning is fake.
Lucia:这就到现在还在红中
Lucia: This is still red now.
Lucia:看这和这个地方
Lucia: Look, this place and that place.
Nicous: 我以为故都是真的
Nicous: I thought everything was real.
Lucia:对现在好像又比我下午好一点了
Lucia: Yeah, it seems a bit better than this afternoon now.
Tasha:都是假的呵呵呵
Tasha: It's all fake, hahaha.
Nicous: 我草那太叼了
Nicous: Damn, that's so awesome.
Katrina: 我当时还特崇拜你来
Katrina: At that time, I really admired you.
Jake:应该还行问题不大
Jake: It should be fine, not a big problem.
Katrina: 不是说只只只只是那个店是假的吗就
Katrina: Didn't they say only, only, only that store was fake?
Lucia:对理论上应该问题不大但是
Lucia: Yeah, theoretically it shouldn't be a big problem, but...
Lucia:规定是必须要至少要打4次或者5针
Lucia: The rule is you have to get at least 4 or 5 shots.
Shure: 哎呀完了腿麻了动不了了
Shure: Oh no, my leg's numb, I can't move.
Lucia:然后最少最少要打4针
Lucia: And at least, at least 4 shots.
Shure: 我靠 哇
Shure: Damn, wow.
Shure: 我靠动不了你帮我拿一会
Shure: Damn, I can't move, can you help me for a bit?
Lucia: 隔一星期打一针
Lucia: One shot every week.
Shure: 我操腿麻了
Shure: Damn, my leg is numb.
Lucia:如果是打4针就是今天要打两针
Lucia: If it's 4 shots, then we need to do two today.
Lucia:对所以我两边都打了一针
Lucia: Yeah, so I got one on each side.
Jake:我以前也被猫抓了
Jake: I was scratched by a cat before.
Jake:然后我我我是我是在美国住一个LMB
Jake: I was living in an Airbnb in the US.
Jake:然后被那边有一只猫抓了
Jake: And a cat there scratched me.
Jake:然后抓了就
Jake: And after it scratched me...
Shure: 没有可乐了
Shure: We're out of Coke.
Shure: 你的可乐就是我的可乐
Shure: Your Coke is my Coke.
Jake:我和房东房东说打过哦
Jake: I told the landlord, and the landlord said I should get a shot.
Jake:然后我我我我也就是
Jake: And then I, I, I, I...
Jake:虽然第一天很慌但是后来也不管了
Jake: Although I was really nervous on the first day, I eventually didn't care anymore.
Nicous: 我草这是人按的
Nicous: Damn, this was pressed by someone.
Lucia:对我今天还专门去咖啡馆问了
Lucia: Yeah, I even went to the cafe today to ask.
Lucia:我说这这小狗有没有疫苗本
Lucia: I asked if this puppy had its vaccination records.
Lucia:然后他们说就是就是
Lucia: And they said, like, um...
Lucia:这个狗现在的疫苗他们还没带去打
Lucia: The dog hasn't been taken for its current vaccines yet.
Lucia:但是就是狗舍说打过
Lucia: But the kennel said it was vaccinated.
Lucia:但是就是狗舍没有给他们给疫苗本
Lucia: But the kennel didn't give them the vaccination records.
Lucia:然后我觉得啊那要不然回去打一下吧
Lucia: So I thought, maybe we should take it for a shot then.
Shure: 不是 那大横按
Shure: No, press it horizontally.
Lucia:对不对
Lucia: Right?
Jake:是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia:所以我就
Lucia: So I...
Lucia:然后我问了一下我我那个我家人
Lucia: Then I asked my family.
Shure: 是的 那大横按
Shure: Yes, press it horizontally.
Lucia:我妈说他朋友养猫
Lucia: My mom said her friend owns a cat.
Lucia:然后被自己家猫抓了
Lucia: And got scratched by her own cat.
Lucia:就也去打了
Lucia: So she also got a shot.
Shure: 我手机呢 嘿 西瑞
Shure: Where's my phone? Hey, Siri.
Lucia:然后我本来想着对
Lucia: And I originally thought, right.
Shure: 在我的
Shure: It's in my...
Lucia:就是我可能很快就打回来了啊
Lucia: Maybe I could get it done quickly.
Nicous: 四指按两个
Nicous: Press with four fingers.
Jake:那小狗没听就没听见
Jake: If the puppy doesn't hear it, it doesn't hear it.
Shure: 不的 一直按
Shure: No, keep pressing.
Tasha: 我说如果没有打疫苗得上狂犬病会怎么样
Tasha: I said, what happens if you get rabies without the vaccine?
Lucia:因为那地方走去其实挺近
Lucia: Because it's actually quite close by.
Tasha:真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Katrina: 百分百致死率
Katrina: 100% fatality rate.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Lucia:对但是那个因为他那是值班嘛
Lucia: Yeah, but the thing is, he was on duty.
Katrina: 百如果你得了是前题
Katrina: If you get it, that's the premise.
Lucia:然后所以我就要等一下
Lucia: So I had to wait a bit.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Tasha: 这么恐怖
Tasha: That's so scary.
Lucia:那个医生
Lucia: That doctor...
Lucia:然后我还要再咨询一下他是怎么回事
Lucia: Then I still need to consult him on what happened.
Shure: 大家有看到我的手机吗
Shure: Has anyone seen my phone?
Lucia:然后所以就稍微晚了一点
Lucia: So it was a bit delayed.
Jake:打个电话
Jake: Make a call.
Shure: 嘿Siri
Shure: Hey Siri
Jake:那个电话
Jake: That phone
Katrina: 疫苗多少钱一针
Katrina: How much is one dose of the vaccine?
Shure: 嘿Siri
Shure: Hey Siri
Katrina: 你那疫苗多少钱一针
Katrina: How much is one dose of your vaccine?
Shure: 在我的iPhone上播放声音算是
Shure: Play a sound on my iPhone
Lucia:算是基本上算是100块钱一针
Lucia: It's basically 100 bucks per dose
Katrina: 哦那还很便宜
Katrina: Oh, that's quite cheap
Lucia:对但是要打五针或者四针
Lucia: Yeah, but you need to take five or four doses
Lucia:就是打四针的话
Lucia: If you take four doses
Lucia:你就是第一天打的时候要打两针
Lucia: You need to get two doses on the first day
Lucia:左右胳膊上各一针
Lucia: One in each arm
Alice:这个疫苗价钱还不一样的吗
Alice: Are there different prices for the vaccine?
Shure: 大横按
Shure: Press the big button
Lucia:对还有300的哦
Lucia: Yes, there's also a 300 one
Alice:哦
Alice: Oh
Lucia:但我觉得300一只有点太夸张了
Lucia: But I think 300 per dose is a bit too much
Lucia:哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 你要把所有的全按住了
Shure: You need to press all of them
Katrina: 他们的功能不都是抑制吗
Katrina: Don't they all just suppress it?
Nicous: 所有的全按上是吧
Nicous: Press all of them, right?
Katrina: 难道还有什么抑制得快一点
Katrina: Is there one that suppresses it faster?
Lucia:好像没啥区别
Lucia: Doesn't seem to be much difference
Shure: 对
Katrina: 对啊
Katrina: Right
Lucia:应该是没啥区别
Lucia: There shouldn't be much difference
Alice:他是根据什么来给你选针的呀
Alice: How do they choose the doses for you?
Alice:不知道
Alice: I don't know
Nicous: 这样
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah
Alice:这100多跟300多有什么区别啊
Alice: What's the difference between the 100 and 300 one?
Lucia:不知道啊
Lucia: I don't know
Lucia:咱也不知道啊
Lucia: I have no idea
Alice:我们之前打了
Alice: We took
Alice:就打完一一个就快2,000
Alice: It cost almost 2,000 after one full course
Katrina: 定歌定歌定歌定歌定歌
Katrina: Sing a song, sing a song, sing a song
Shure: 定歌快快定完歌
Shure: Hurry up and finish the song
Lucia:如果300多就打完了就是1500对吧
Lucia: If it's 300 each, it's 1500 in total, right?
Shure: 我睡觉觉
Shure: I'm going to sleep
Alice:那个好像三针
Alice: That one requires three doses
Alice:我也不知道
Alice: I don't know either.
Alice:反正我妈去打的
Alice: Anyway, my mom went to get it.
Katrina: 他们要严逼了
Katrina: They're getting really strict.
Lucia:我妈他朋友打的就
Lucia: My mom's friend went to get it too.
Lucia:也是100块钱一针的
Lucia: It was also 100 yuan per shot.
Katrina: 要不听一下这歌
Katrina: How about we listen to this song?
Katrina: 这应该合唱出来会好听
Katrina: It might sound better as a chorus.
Nicous: 这正常吗
Nicous: Is this normal?
Lucia:希望我今天晚上不要发烧
Lucia: I hope I don't get a fever tonight.
Shure: 正常啥
Shure: What's normal?
Lucia:医生说常见的副作用是可能会发烧
Lucia: The doctor said a common side effect is a fever.
Jake:哦就是打疫苗发烧
Jake: Oh, so getting a fever after the vaccine.
Lucia:对打疫苗发烧对
Lucia: Yeah, a fever after the vaccine.
Shure: 来先听一下下歌
Shure: Let's listen to the song first.
Shure: 听一下歌
Shure: Listen to the song.
Shure: 这首歌大家听过吗
Shure: Has everyone heard this song before?